mad flavor here
different locations exotic locales
that's how I do it [ __ ] when
coming to you on a remote for the
balcony of death
just checking in with you [ __ ] Savage
I don't want you I don't want you to
think that uncle Joey forgot about you
[ __ ] Joey pussied out of us
check your clock [ __ ] it's like 7am
here and uncle Joey's on his second
[ __ ] number already had oatmeal I had
some [ __ ] had my blood pressure
medication I took a walk around and I'm
over here making it happen you know I'm
sounding a solo tip sometimes you gotta
do what you gotta do I ain't getting the
pipe falls I'm getting from that [ __ ]
thing but this weeds on fire today
that's it I just want to let you know I
never forget about you just cuz I'm on
location don't mean uncle Joey ain't got
your [ __ ] back I always got your back
smoked and read for explosives whatever
you need this is this is his perfect
this gets some Sun a number and Uncle
Joe is like I totally a damn better than
[ __ ] Kellogg's all right Kellogg's
don't do for you what I do for you you
know what are you going to you know why
they don't do these things but they
thing will not bring up a lot because I
love you that's why that's why cuz I
love you you ever tell you that what do
you let them you got PP got their kids
walking around I don't give a [ __ ] this
is California shits on the menu now
oh my god i love getting this I in the
morning cuz you never know what's gonna
happen I'm doing a couple station time
doing Don Jeronimo I'm doing some other
one earlier and then I'm doing my little
brother from North Bergen Billy
horrendous me and Billy grew up in the
same Delhi together and not Bergen New
Jersey called hash ways that's how we do
it [ __ ] never forget that's it that's
it that's all I know big [ __ ] mystery
to this you wash your dick you write
your goals you smoke a number you eat
your breakfast and you attack that's it
attack attack attack attack attack who
gives a [ __ ] eventually you get tired
and you die and you move on but that's
it you know I love you mother [ __ ]
we're all my heart you gotta do what you
gotta do to the don't take [ __ ] from
nobody and at the end of the day take it
all suck your dick you understand me
that they don't suck it today give him a
week or two they'll change their mind
always remember ain't nobody better than
you stay black uncle Joey loves you I'll
catch you [ __ ] this afternoon
i'm gonna move stable i gotta take a
morning [ __ ] to make the day complete
love you
you